what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so Gerry Dugan is perhaps one of the
best comic book writers is out there
right now because it takes a kind of
skill to be able to write a story that
is one part humor and one part
seriousness but blend them together in a
way where you never know how it's going
to switch from one theme to the other or
sometimes they're both combined but for
some reason or another Gerry Dugan is
able to do it so it's it is kind of
intriguing now there are a couple things
that go into this because honestly we
have not covered all-new all-different
guardians of the galaxy and maybe we can
but this sets the stage for the hunt for
the Infinity stones it's really what
this is those are the guys who have been
keeping track of Marvel legacy and the
things that have been going on the
general idea is that it's going to see
this sort of segue into the return of
the Infinity stones now a lot of that
was announced with Marvel legacy first
launch and a lot of that's designed to
segue into the launch of infinity war in
May so I mean it kind of makes sense to
go that route but it is interesting
because what this initially does is this
picks up with the Brotherhood of the
Raptors now the Brotherhood of the
Raptors is actually a group that
appeared back in war of kings and
they're basically a splinter group from
the traditional Shiar empire is really
all they are of course the CR Empire is
the spacefaring race it's really more of
an amalgamation of races that also are
Failte to like the existing Emperor or
you know Empress but there are splinter
like militaristic groups you know those
individuals who have just broken off
from the main Shiar Empire itself and
gone off to do their own thing and what
this does is it actually picks up with a
guy by the name of town on now talon r
is the brother of richard rider his
actual name is robert rider but he's one
of these characters that and we talked
about this before when we gone where
we've gone through like you know
character explanations and so on he's
one of these characters who is
originally introduced way back in like
1976 and then reworked and that really
happens with like a lot of different
characters who are out there and it's
cool because in the all you know the the
free comic book day i think it was for
all new guardians of the galaxy the
story of town are was basically reworked
to essentially say that at some point
along the line robert ryder was a member
of the Nova court but ultimately he fell
in with the raptors was really kind of
shanghaied in and then subjected to
brainwashing that kind of warped his
mind and then drove him to swear
absolute loyalty to the Raptors
themselves and eventually kind of take
over the group and so that's really one
of the reasons why are really the
biggest reason why he's a main villain
here now there is some backup that goes
on with regards to this tidbit in the
sense that there is something called the
nega bands none
bans themselves those go back quite some
time I mean those go back all the way to
like 1969 with Captain Marvel number 16
I think but the biggest reason why
Toland are has them here and the biggest
reason why they're so sought-after for
the most part is because they allow a
kind of cosmic awareness now in truth
cosmic awareness is the rule is a roll
of the dice there's no guarantee that
because you wield the nega bans that
you'll have cosmic awareness but the
whole idea is that if kolinar has the
Negev ann's which he does and if you can
get them to work and he achieves cosmic
awareness he'll be able to locate the
Infinity stones and so that's the whole
basis behind this is being able to
understand you know everything that's
going on and and where it all comes to
you now the whole idea behind how he
attained them is that originally star
Lord had won and then Robert Rider had
won and in order to basically strike a
bargain of sorts what ended up happening
is you know star-lord basically handed
his over but actually threw it through a
portal and it ended up sitting Tolan are
into this other planet where basically
everybody been converted into Ultron's
much the same way that we saw in
annihilation conquest and we'll revisit
that in this particular video but it is
kind of a cool idea because essentially
the long and short of this is that Tolan
are now has the negeb ants to himself
and he's trying to get them to work in
unison and so at this point we pick up
with the Nova Corps itself now remember
a lot of this is kind of like a
reworking of the whole Nova Corps
concept it's kind of a repeating cycle
in a lot of ways in the sense that the
Nova Corps was Marvel's answer to DC's
Green Lantern Corps but the idea was
that the Nova Corps was effectively
wiped out during the events of
annihilation
I can never if it was a violation or
annihilation conquest but while the Nova
Corps kind of experienced these waxes
and wanes doers effectively pushed to
the brink of extinction and annihilated
now eventually they were recreated by
the world mind and which is basically
the source of energy that the that
Richard Reiter got his power from that
all the Nova Corps members get their
power from there was recreated by the
world mind the world mind was operating
basically outside of Richard Rider when
Richard realized what was going on he
was effectively banished and then he
retook the Nova the Nova prime mantle
and then after the world mine and then
basically shut down the Nova Corps there
were a lot of things that went on with
regards to that whole history and you'll
find that in my video on Richard Rider
explained that'll cover everything that
you guys want to know really going up to
this point now there really wasn't a
Nova Corps you kind of had one to a
degree but there wasn't really a Nova
Corps in terms of how it exists now it
was largely just Richard rider and Sam
Alexander and then like you know the
hunt for Sam Alexander's dad and that
was really all there was to it so at
this point it's a rebuilding phase but
because of the fact that the
Accor at its peak was one of the most
powerful forces in the universe there
are a lot of eyes watching this a lot of
people who are curious about what's
going on now what this does is it brings
in the guardians who have basically
joined the Nova Corps it is kind of
interesting but one character also want
you guys to take note of here is ant-man
now a lot of this comes out of secret
Empire in the sense that were the whole
secret Empire event taking place ant-man
basically betraying the resistance for
the most part handing information over
to the forces of Hydra once the whole
conflict ended and his loyalty to the
superhero community was called into
question it was really more of like a
crisis of conscience and you know
ant-man Scott Lane just kind of said
look I just want to leave disappear and
so what he did is literally book passage
with the guardians of the galaxy when
they left Earth for the intention of
walking away and that's why as you read
this story you know if you leave when
you get out and you buy it you read
through it what you'll find is OB
references to nowhere like the last stop
for people who wanted as appear they
basically go to nowhere this sort of
cosmic hangout this cosmic bar on the
edge of the universe and then it is kind
of vanished from there they just booked
passage towards some ship and usually
people never hear from them again
because they don't want to be heard from
again and so I get it is pretty
intriguing the funny thing about this is
that the guardians are on the hunt for
the Infinity stones but it's also a
little bit of humor that gets thrown in
here you know some funny moments to take
place what we end up having for instance
is this at this point where rocket
racoon talks to one of the guys named a
sloth I think it is and Terk sloth
worked as a security adviser on his
planet that has like a lot of fine art
and different things like that and
rocket racoon is casing the joint he's
like hey man ah your planet how's fine
art and things like that right like very
expensive artwork and you know the guys
like yeah man it did I was a security
consultant and Rockets like good like
tell me everything you know just so that
we can make sure that their planet is
defended adequately it's small little
things like that that really kind of
bring in these these funny moments and
again it kind of continues on Rocket
Raccoon has really been brought in here
alongside the other guardians to really
kind of test and vet the members of the
Nova Corps because with the team
basically basically being reformed
there's a lot of people who are looking
to bring it down there's a lot of people
who are looking to either destroy it in
its entirety or to infiltrate it for a
variety of reasons just to kind of spy
on them and see how things are going but
you know along the way when you end up
having like you know Gamora in the end
up having Scott Lang who were basically
checking out this distress signal more
or less where a massive number of people
are presumed to have died what we end up
having is them showing up alongside you
know several other members
of the noble Court and discovering the
entire place has been overrun with
Ultron robots now this is really
designed to be a homage to like
annihilation conquest as well as picking
up on the idea that like the Ultron
virus has spread now the cool thing
about this is remember annihilation
conquest was basically a story where the
essence of Ultron had been just kind of
jettisoned into space by the Avengers
and that eventually took over a group
called the Phalanx who's kind of weird
to describe them but they're like
walking talking machines all trying to
taken over them and then like began
conquering portions of the universe so
it was actually pretty cool in terms of
how that happened but of course that's
exactly what's happening here you know
Ultron Ultron virus is effectively
spreading but if you're going through
this and you start to see that there's
like a measure of familiarity between
the you know guardians of the galaxy or
like the Nova Corps in terms of like
what's happening with the spread of
these Ultron's
that's because of annihilation conquests
because it's happened before of course
it's interesting because with this whole
you know community being overrun by
Ultron's they're there to rescue a
handful of people the problem is that
once they get out there the ship they
brought is basically gone and it's funny
because a couple of these folks are like
dude we were better like we were safer
when we were hiding you're here to
rescue us and now we're all gonna die
which is kind of cool but what we end up
finding out is that while this ship was
sitting in dock with the crew waiting
for you know the other members of the
Nova Corps for Gamora and Scott Lane to
come back did the ship in more or less
early so look like this ship was gonna
be overrun by these Ultron's it was
really one of those let's get out of
here and then let's come back once
they're gone
grab the rest of our team and survivors
and let's get out of here it is pretty
interesting in terms of how it unfolds
and how it works again you know with
like rocker baku for example going
through you've got members of the Nova
Corps who were like looting derelict
ships you know ships that have been
caught by the Nova Corps you know
because they were just kind of adrift in
space for whatever reason you know and
you have members of the Corps who are
looting it taking clothes taking alcohol
different things like that again it's
very much designed to hit the idea that
there's some pretty seedy elements to
the Nova Corps that in desperate times
you get what you can now the other half
of this is that this also deals with
star-lord basically learning that
Richard Ryder is alive now
Richard Ryder was basically the jumping
off platform for the for everything that
is the Nova Corps it all started with
Richard Ryder younger people who are
who've been picking up comics within the
last 10 years probably think of Sam
Alexander
but Richard Ryder was the one who kicked
it all off and he was always kind of the
frontrunner for the Nova Corps and in
the early comics you learned as he
learned you know when he first became
Nova and was taken to Xander and learned
the hive ma I'm sorry the world mind
about the Nova Corps itself it was very
much in tune with the old Green Lantern
stories but you followed Richard rider
along his journey now over the years and
Marvel Comics his stories have been
expanded and things of wax and waned
there was a pretty strong friendship
that formed between star-lord and
Richard Rider and this really came to a
head in the Thanos imperative when you
had the cancer verse basically a rift
that formed between the main Marvel
Universe and this other universe where
nobody could die because death was
destroyed and so when that led into the
whole fan of imperative story and those
villains came pouring out and so on and
so forth ultimately it took Thanos
Richard rider and star-lord entering
into the cancer verse to bring it all to
an end the idea behind this was at
star-lord eventually escaped
Richard Rider and and and famous were
left behind Thanos eventually escaped
and then Richard mightor was stuck there
now when Richard Ryder eventually
returned a Sam Alexander was the first
one to learn about it so of course Sam
Alexander Richard Ryder teamed up and
there was some cool storytelling that
went on there but Richard Ryder never
got back into contact with star-lord and
so as it stands right now at the time of
this story's being written Peter quill
is just now learning that Richard Ryder
is alive and it's kind of a betrayal of
friendship because they fought together
during anihilation they fought side by
side against overwhelming odds with all
those things that have happened the
sacrifice of the can servers all that's
taking place the biggest thought that
Peter quill would have had is look when
Richard Ryder comes back he would have
sought me out what Peter quill doesn't
know is a lot of things were going on
there the world mind that Richard Ryder
had used I was them was one of the means
by which he made his escape along with
the Cosmic Cube the world mind felt
betrayed the world mind took over the
cancerverse
when Richard Ryder effectively came back
he had to contend with all that stuff
there are a lot of things that were
going on and really getting back into
contact with star-lord was the least of
his concerns but it is kind of cool
because it's one of those things were
it's like okay look we're back together
now we're friends now we'll deal with
this later at the moment we've got
bigger fish to fry and so what they're
doing is they're basically seeking after
a handful of members of the Nova Corps
who had basically defected who had
walked away and no one really knew why
they were just trying to figure out what
had gone on now the belief initially was
that they had lost faith in the core or
they had gone off to perform their own
goal or whatever the case may have been
but once they get in there they're
basically attacked by a pregnant member
of the Nova Corps which is really kind
of cool but once they figure out that
she's pregnant what she does when
everything kind of stands down you know
she's you know that's hey look I'm
Richard Ryder and hey look everything's
cool like like everybody chill you know
we're all good
what we end up finding out here is that
this place is essentially home to the
power stone to the infinity stone now I
want to talk about this for a second
because I've seen different posts where
people talk about the power stone and
what the power stone does one of the
misconceptions people have is the power
stone serves the purpose of just
amplifying power the idea of the power
stone is it doesn't necessarily grant
people any power that they want to I
mean it can if a person knows how to use
it correctly but if you just walk up to
it and touch it then all it does is
amplify whatever you have so in the case
of a human it'll give you super strength
if you're a telepath it'll elevate your
telepathy it simply just exists to kind
of elevate what abilities you have now
and terms of its relation to the other
Infinity stones what it basically does
is it serves as a kind of bedrock the
power stone is a source of infinite
power and so it essentially operates as
the foundation by essentially providing
a power source for all the other stones
so that they can all work in unison now
again it has waxed and waned I mean when
they when the the power stone was first
put in the hands of like the champion of
the universe for example all it did is
simply just make him stronger and
allowing him to fight for a longer
amount of time but that has to come
along and said well you're doing that
because you don't know how to use it
effectively in reality the power stone
will actually give you any power you
want you just don't know how to use it
that way now of course again this is
kind of cool because it hits on that
with with with star-lord where he
basically crushes a gun with his bare
hands because it you know amplifies his
own strength the problem with this is
that an infinity stone having been
located is no small thing an infinity
stone flows are floating out there you
know having been located will basically
lead to like a great gold rush of
virtually every race in existence trying
to find it because remember the stones
want to be found that was confirmed
during the whole like Illuminati
storyline all you have to find is just
one Infinity stone and then it will lead
you to the others because they all want
to be brought together in unison and so
again that's why it's a big deal because
it'll serve as a tracking device for all
the other stones now the other half of
this is that with rocket racoon going
through and locating these various
individuals and so on and so forth again
it's just kind of the the nova corps
performing these small acts to kind of
regain trust in humanity for example
there's another SOS s and how if Drax
the destroyer along had a handful of
other nova corps members show up and
they find basically a woman and a few
kids who are just kind of hanging out
there and they've been captured by
members of the Nova Corps some of them
want to basically eliminate them of
course Drax stops that from happening it
says look it's not okay to take an
innocent life these people don't pose
any real threat it's a live and let live
kind of thing well then this is a
Roback to like 1960s 1970s comics
because you have this chick who just
kind of blasts neo Drax the destroyer
with telepathy it says hey look we're
good guys but these members of the Nova
Corps they're actually spies for the
fraternity of Raptors they're spies for
the Shiar and they're trying to find a
way to infiltrate the the Nova Corps and
bring it down which is cool because
Jackson Astoria immediately turns on
these guys now at this point reactive
stories kind of walked away from the
life of killing which has been a
repeating cycle for his character I mean
there's been points where he's like look
I'm only a peacekeeping guy I don't
really want to destroy things I don't
want to kill things and then that kind
of grows stale after a while and so
Marvel switches it back over and says
okay so like Drax our destroyers gonna
start killing stuff again it is kind of
cool in terms of how that plays out that
evolution of his character but
ultimately he's basically the one that
saves his family he eliminates these
spies and then you know this family kind
of goes along their way and then that's
really the end of that but again it's
designed to hit at the idea that the
Nova Corps is not as strong as we
originally you know as it used to be in
the sense of this filled with criminals
filled with spies people who were
looking to gain the upper hand on all
the information that's there Drax the
destroyer is having a hard time dealing
with the situation so he basically goes
and puts on jungle land by Bruce
Springsteen which is kind of interesting
it's kind of funny it's like it's the
only thing they could call me down he
starts to play the saxophone it's
actually pretty amazing it's very much
capturing the essence of the guardians
of the galaxy films and throwing it in
the comic book form which is a beautiful
thing to see is actually pretty amazing
but following this of course again there
is another SOS and this SOS really kind
of comes out of nowhere again this
cosmic bar that just kind of floats out
there and you end up having like what
looks like groot tearing things up you
know now of course this version of Groot
is basically destroyed and it's
destroyed by Cosmo now Cosmo I don't
think you've ever really talked about
him before the Cosmo is basically a
Russian telepathic dog who is the head
of security in nowhere I know it sounds
bonkers but like believe me when I tell
you Cosmo has a fan base and they are
dedicated they love Cosmo I'm one of
them I love the idea of Cosmo is
hilarious because he just speaks
telepathically the funniest thing about
him though is how people react to him
the idea of like hey so like this is a
telepathic dog that has a Russian accent
it's kind of weird like it was it was
always kind of a funny answer that
question if a person has an accident and
they have telepathy dessert 11 'they
come in the form of an accent like does
the person who speak japanese think in
japanese I don't know I always thought
that was kind of an interesting question
but it is kind of cool because
we basically pick up with the idea that
like all these floral colossi are just
tearing things to pieces they're ripping
things up but this was cool because this
is actually a throwback to the very
first appears of Groot originally when
rip first showed up it was in a series
of stories that involve the Incredible
Hulk really it was the Incredible Hulk
going against a villain well this
villain had brought in like all these
different enemies but fighting against
against Groot it was basically just like
this floor colossi and that was it it
was just a giant tree and The Incredible
Hulk smashed it to pieces turned into a
tree stump and that was really about it
it was a pretty short fight it was like
three pages long but it was kind of
interesting because what ended up
happening is Marvel uses to kind of
rework the character of Groot and then
bring him back in as the character that
we all know now but it is cool because
we get a throwback to that basically
saying hey look the reason why that
original version of Groot existed is
because it was the creature from Planet
X that's how he was originally billed
and so because of that it was a way for
Marvel to come along and say Groot is
just one of a multitude of different
creatures that all are basically walking
talking trees or intz if you want to
call them that but it is kind of cool
because it basically hit at this idea
that there are more versions of them now
by and large it was always believed
Groot was the last of his kind
that there were no other versions of him
and so what this means is that someone's
creating more groups this leads to the
Guardians basically facing off against
this evil version of Groot having to you
know burn them to pieces or so on and so
forth but it is an army of these things
and it's kind of funny because Drax is
like look I I can't do it I can't bring
myself to kill and burn another being
and groups like I can and like burns
this through to pieces which is pretty
brutal when you think about it but again
because of the fact of their villains
and because of the fact that they're bad
guys they're dealt with pretty swiftly
but again it says on to kind of hit it
all this stuff all these things are
happening all at the same time and when
it comes to all these evil versions of
roots the question is who's creating
them where are they coming from how are
they getting here and so the initial
indication that's put off is that well
they're being created by the gardener
the gardener is just one of these elders
of the universe now this again goes to
hit back at the idea that it really kind
of repeats the old stories of like
Thanos quest when Thanos is tracking
down all the Infinity stones and the
gardener was in possession of the time
stone that the gardener had is the
gardener was warping time around him and
using that to like speed up the growth
of the things that he was making he
didn't really realize as what he was
doing but that's what he was doing and
then Thanos kind of like screwed up the
gardener in a pretty messed-up way it
was actually pretty rough he looked
pretty brutal
by the time tano's got done with him but
the fact remains here that what does it
have
is the whole idea of group was to go
through and find all the crooked members
of the Nova Court and then in turn throw
them all in cells and basically just
arrest them and say you're all going to
be discharged and you all have disgraced
the Nova court mantle now this is funny
and this was actually really cool
because what this does it shows how
smart rocket racoon is rockets one of
those characters were is very easy to
kind of swoop him under the rug and say
he's just the guy who loves guns but
he's actually really really smart here
what he does is he tells the local
leader of the Nova Corps the reason why
I did this is because there's two types
of people in this world there are people
who were squeaky clean and there are
people who have committed crimes and
done shady things but the ones who are
squeaky clean are usually the bad guys
and that's what it is that he says here
he says look what you have is you have
these members of the Nova Corps who
basically are just whatever their
planets would send out to join the Nova
Corps because nobody really trusts the
Nova Corps yet so they're not gonna send
their best soldiers they're gonna send
the second best or the third best so you
get the ones who are a little shady who
are Lee you know who are a little rough
around the edges but that's because
nobody wants to send you the good guys
what that means is if there are people
here who are squeaky clean and who have
never never committed any bad acts it's
because they're lying they're spies for
the fraternity of Raptors because if
they're gonna get caught for something
it's not gonna be for you know stealing
or looting or anything like that and so
it's basically rocket saying the guys
who never did anything bad the guys that
I don't have anything on those are your
spies these guys they're your average
soldiers they're the only members of the
Nova Corps you can trust and it's funny
because this guy's response is so the
only members of the Nova Corps that I
can trust are the ones who are on the
take and it's and it's kind of funny but
it's so smart and it's absolutely genius
because it was a way for rocket to
separate those who were legitimate
members of the team from those who were
spies and so at that point is basically
grabbing arms and armament putting them
all in a giant container taking it back
to the guys who were locked up and
saying look you're the only ones that we
can trust and so at this point we got to
take out the fraternity of the
fraternity of the Raptors that was cool
because these fraternity of Raptors
spies don't know what Rockets doing and
so when they report back to town are
their argument is hey these guys are
bumbling buffoons man like you guys
won't believe it they arrested everybody
who wasn't us they believe were the good
guys
they're gonna be helpless to stop us and
is cool and so with Talon on making his
move attacking the guardians of the
galaxy this basically leads to you know
the Guardians and the Nova Corps going
to war against Hal and are himself which
ends pretty swiftly as you would expect
now at this point we transition away
from the guardians of the galaxy and
weep
with the return of one of my favorite
characters Adam warlock now Adam
warlocks return here is ambiguous at
best we know nothing about this all we
know is that Adam warlock is basically
in Soul world and that's it now there's
a reason why cheery Duggan's doing this
Adam warlock in the soul jump go
hand-in-hand and it's always been that
way that was the first soul stone Adam
warlock had and I want to say the the
soul stone was the first soul stone or
the first Infinity stone to ever appear
in Marvel Comics but the whole idea
behind this is that because Adam warlock
was in possession of the soul stone for
so long that a piece of his soul itself
had kind of leached out into soul world
meaning he is part and parcel to the
soul stone that's why when things like
the you know the Infinity watch were
formed we're basically the Infinity
stones are being guarded by various
people Thanos Gamora moon dragon pip the
trolls so on and so forth Adam warlock
head on to the soul stone because it's
part and parcel to who he is it's a part
of him now the other half of this is him
going through he's just kind of seeing
how things are progressing if it's the
past the present the future he's not
giving given any definitive answers here
and the soul stone is just kind of a
reflection of who you are it's just a
reflection of viewers of being in terms
of how you perceive it it is also its
own individual world but the fact
remains here that Adam warlock is there
Adam warlock is inside the soul stone so
what is kind of intriguing here now the
other half of this is that with this
final battle between the guardians of
the galaxy and you know the the Tollan
are the forces of Han are and the the
fraternity of Raptors it goes exactly as
you would expect they do have a bit of a
bit of genius here in the simpson none
of the Nova Corps weapons will penetrate
the shields of at ownership so basically
what they do is it is kind of send a
beam of light ant-man shrinks down to
the size of a photon boards the ship and
then just grows to a giant size and
destroys the entirety of the ship but it
is kind of interesting of course telling
our retreats and that's really the end
of that I mean things end quick fast and
in a hurry when it comes to that final
battle of course Richard Ryder appears
saying hey look you know I'm ready to
help but of course everything's already
done and it's already concluded but the
funny thing about this is because Jack's
a destroyer has taken more of like a
peaceful approach more of like a monk
approach what Peter quill does is grab
Drax and take him to where the Power
Stone is and he's effectively going to
be the Guardian here now the idea is
that no one knows about the Power Stone
Drax is really supposed to be this
Guardian the guy that keys are protected
but it's funny because we end up finding
out that when Peter quill was having a
conversation about the Power Stone when
he had mentioned that it had been
overheard because one of the
shape-shifting Scrolls was stowed aboard
the Nova Corps they were spying and they
heard it so they reports of the scrolls
you in turn have someone who basically
gets a piece of information from one of
the other member
the nova corps who reports a directly to
them basically this woman named - Linda
you end up having the Ultron robots who
know about the souls about the Power
Stone you have like this Atari who take
to Linda and they're like we'll give you
what bargain your life the reward you
will receive for giving us a location of
the Power Stone is like being able to
continue living so it's basically this
idea that now everyone knows where the
Power Stone is and everyone is vying for
its location and everybody's gonna try
to track it down so it's so imagine the
original Thanos quest storyline but
imagine that story lines been modified
so that everyone is trying to find the
Infinity stones it actually sets the
stage for some pretty amazing
storytelling now switching back to Adam
warlock this gives us a piece of
storytelling that we didn't have before
what we actually end up learning is that
go a portion of Gamora soul is trapped
inside the soul stone we didn't know
that there was no reason to believe that
what this does is it establishes the
idea that the soul stone takes no
prisoners that everyone is is brought
into the soul zone in some form of
fashion if you're in there long enough
it will take a piece of your soul and so
Gamora has been aging inside here and
that portion of Gamora wants to leave
now the what this could do is it could
serve as a purpose to basically returned
Gamora to the quote-unquote way she used
to be where she was violent where she
was just an assassin it would be a way
to basically say okay now Gamora can go
off and do her own thing she can go back
to the way she was back in like the 80s
now that part of her soul is back and
she's her whole self but Adam warlock
basically says look I'm not in
possession of the soul stone so I'm not
bound to this place I'm not required to
be here and so what he does is he
effectively leaves and he wakes up and
when he does wake up we end up finding
out that he's in the presence of Kang
the Conqueror why he's in the presence
of came to conquer we don't know we
simply just know that he's there but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys have this sub button to become
part of the robb cork if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah from here it continues on into the
infinity countdown Adam warlock one shot
into the infinity countdown prime
basically everything that leads into the
whole main infinity countdown storyline
that leads into infinity war presumably
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]